I think collectively we should be all
together at the table much more often
than we are because i think that the
table is such a magnet for interaction
from the family onto world issues its
food is a conduit venue that we can sort
of permeate each other's thoughts and
also at the table beginning with the
family and the family eating together to
the leaders giving each other's food at
the table may be discussing the point
and issue over a nice bowl of pasta I
think individually we should have a
consciousness of ourself of our body of
living well and using food to get there
in a positive fashion you know using
food to give us pleasure using food to
lose those few pounds enjoyably not in a
negative negation because I think today
food is negative a lot you know no no no
instead food is es es es is the right
food is the right amount at the right
time